ce soir gloire à toi Satan un tes deux
principes sacrés virilité fertilité
descends dans ton serviteur qui célèbre
ton culte je signe ce pacte de mon sang
gloire à toi Satan
[Musique]
incroyable mais vrai ce document
l'équipe du magazine vendredi la tournée
en plein Paris au mois de juin il y a
environ 4 semaines comme ça normalement
intact avec Satan au moment du triomphe
des sciences du 10 ans 15 ans après le
voyage dans la lune impacte avec Satan
des documents comme ceci nous pouvons
vous en proposer et nous allons vous en
proposer plusieurs dans la soirée de
documents exclusifs dont l'un je dois le
dire tout de suite est un document assez
assez fort assez assez dur c'est un
exorcisme c'est-à-dire c'est un
désenvoûtement le désenvoûtement d'une
personne qui est où se croit possédé par
le diable par un religieux
vous l'avez deviné vous le savez nous
allons faire ce soir un voyage au pays
de la sorcellerie
sorcellerie mystification escroquerie
fête société nous avons ce soir des
témoignages les reportages des
débatteurs qui suivent de près
l'actualité du Diable nous aurions pu
nous installer n'importe où en France
pour faire ce numéro spécial de vendredi
de France à la 3 en Mayenne en Corse au
Pays Basque dans les Ardennes car la
sorcellerie c'est un fait même très
profond qui existe toujours mais nous
sommes ici ce soir dans le Puy-de-Dôme
et nous allons commencer ce voyage à
partir d'un petit village ce n'est pas
du tout par hasard andréel puisque vous
allez nous expliquer pourquoi nous
sommes ici à Saint-Anthème et bien tout
simplement parce qu'il y a ici un très
très bel exemple de sorcellerie paysanne
je crois qu'il faut mesurer ce qui se
passe ici ce soir dans la mesure où
c'est la première fois qu'une chaîne de
télévision française réalise un direct à
partir d'une ferme ensorcelée ou
prétendue comme
alors en ce qui concerne la carte
postale André Campana vient de vous le
dire nous sommes ici au cœur de
l'Auvergne près de Saint-Anthème 950
habitants Saint-Anthème le bourg typique
de la région Auvergne Saint-Antoine qui
est paraît-il la commune la plus étendue
de France et tout cela se situe dans un
site merveilleux qui est le parc naturel
du livre Adoua Forez alors point n'est
besoin ce soir de forcer le trait dans
la mesure où il n'y a pas loin d'ici le
col de la Croix de l'homme mort ainsi
que le virage du pendu sans oublier la
fameuse Vallée de l'enfer que voilà je
n'invente rien je vous jure que cette
vallée porte le nom de vallée de l'enfer
du nom du petit cours d'eau qui la
traverse de part en part et au cœur de
cette vallée vous le voyez la ferme qui
nous accueille ici ce soir une ferme
dont l'histoire est proprement
incroyable cela fait 11 ans que cela
dure 11 ans de tracasseries qui se sont
traduites par la mort d'une cinquantaine
de achètes des vaches des brebis des
lapins seuls les poules ont été épargnés
on ne sait pas trop pourquoi il y a
également les habitants de cette ferme
on constaté qu'il y avait de temps en
temps de gros cailloux plusieurs
dizaines de kilos qui tombaient sur leur
ligne alors dès que nous avons été
informés lorsque je dis nous il s'agit
de la télévision régionale la station
régionale de Clermont-Ferrand nous avons
décidé de réaliser un reportage
journalistique c'est-à-dire de constater
des faits reportage qui a été réalisé au
mois d'avril je vous propose d'en voir
un court extrait histoire de se mettre
tout de suite dans l'ambiance
[Musique]
enfer et damnation dans le Puy-de-Dôme
un Christ épinglé c'est le symbole de
cette histoire où les épingles ont un
rôle prépondérant
[Musique]
c'est dans une maison de Saint-Anthème
au cœur du Forez côtoie l'irréelle
depuis 1974
l'effet des épingles retrouvés dans la
panse des vaches de Mesdames juquel et
tournebies toutes leurs vaches brebis
lapin ont ainsi été décimés par ces
épingles maudites malgré le collier
d'ail dont l'objectif est d'éloigner les
esprits et pourtant elles sont
particulièrement croyantes et ne
s'expliquent pas ces étranges phénomènes
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé depuis tout à
l'heure là
mais là montre tout à l'heure et oui oui
oui oui
tout de suite après un petit moment
après
il y en a beaucoup d'épingles
qu'est-ce que vous allez en faire
brûler comme d'habitude quoi
et si vous si vous êtes là et partirons
pas absente
et des vaches justement que elles sont
toutes tes périple par les aiguilles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en combien de temps
et les voisins personne n'a perdu
c'est la sorcellerie
mais c'est bien provoqué par quelque
chose bien sûr
une des grandes questions que nous
allons essayer de d'élucider ce soir
dernière manifestation des épingles
c'était hier soir mesdames juquet les
Tournebise comment vous expliquer ces
phénomènes d'abord vous confirmez cela
fait 11 ans que ça dure et toutes vos
bêtes pratiquement ont disparu en raison
de ses épingles comment vous expliquer
ces phénomènes c'est difficile pour nous
pour nous expliquer
très difficile nous croyez au diable
l'existence du diable
et vous êtes effrayé par tout par
l'impact de cette information
vous avez vu beaucoup de journalistes la
première fois
ça ne vous fait pas peur
vous avez une explication sur la
présence de ces aiguilles ça peut être
ce n'est pas obligatoirement de la
sorcellerie
ben oui mais enfin c'est bien provoqué
par quelque chose c'est pour ça que je
vous demande à votre avis par quoi
[Musique]
ce n'est pas provoqué par une
malveillance
alors là
et 11 ans de tracasseries ça vous a
coûté de l'argent pour essayer de
d'endiguer ce phénomène c'est sûr parce
que comme on a perdu toutes les bêtes ça
nous a ça nous a pris un rapporté après
et vous avez fait appel à des exorcis le
dernier en date est ici nous allons nous
entretenir avec lui vous avez payé des
gens ça vous a coûté combien d'argent
il n'y a pas marqué
c'est des gens qui viennent bien pour
nous aider oui bien alors depuis trois
mois c'est un exercice qui s'occupe de
vous j'en connais qu'est-ce que vous
faites exactement
des exercices c'est à dire que bon
séjour une cliente m'a apporté journal
parce que j'ai pas le temps et j'ai vu
ces gens dans la peine donc
j'ai proposé mes services vous vous êtes
exorciste de métier vous avez un autre
métier non je fais plus que ça
maintenant c'est à dire vous vivez de ça
je vis de ça et vous prenez de l'argent
non le client ce qu'il veut parce que
vous savez il y a des gens riches il y a
des grandes pauvres donc
les personnes de ce qu'elle veut aussi
un peu pompier vous savez à peu près les
mettre le couteau sous la gorge et on a
des efforts
combien d'exercices que j'ai réalisé je
me suis déplacé
quatre fois dans cette maison une nuit
j'ai dû faire en tout cet exercice parce
que je fais chez moi aussi et à votre
avis ces épingles viennent d'où oh c'est
quelqu'un qui rachète
un sort et vous vous avez la capacité de
contrecarrer cette action ben j'essaye
alors qu'est-ce que vous faites
concrètement les exercices
bon bah que des prières toute façon tout
se passe par prière c'est-à-dire on
donne un ordre aux malins Satan belzébus
tous les noms que vous voulez on donne
un ordre à sa tante de partir
vous avez bon espoir de régler ce cas
parce que les aiguilles bon quand je
suis arrivé ici il y avait des boules
des boules de billets en fin de compte
c'était des amalgames d'aiguilles et au
bout du quatrième exercice même au bout
du 3e ce sont des bouts d'aiguilles qui
restent les aiguilles sont cassées des
têtes d'aiguilles c'est vraiment un bel
exemple de
le cas disons que moi je vois par
rapport à l'exorciste que j'ai fait donc
j'ai vu ces boules des aiguilles après
j'ai vu ces aiguilles cette année et
maintenant je vois que des des têtes
d'épingles donc si maintenant il y a
d'autres manifestations c'est le linge
qui s'envole maintenant ce que ça peut
donner de ce côté là vous
personnellement vous croyez en
l'existence du diable ah bah bien sûr
parce que je le combat
je vous remercie bonne chance on va
continuer le diable nous en parlions je
crois que c'est ce soir outre quelques
invités de marque que c'est l'invité
d'honneur disons d'André campagne
bon en tous les cas nous avons beaucoup
de gens qui suivent les allées et venus
du diable on va parler d'abord un peu de
cette affaire de la ferme de
Saint-Anthème peut-être avant d'en
parler complétons rapidement le dossier
je vous propose il y a une instruction
qui a été ouverte nous avons eu accès à
au dossier d'instruction puisqu'il y a
eu un non-lieu et donc au rapport de
gendarmerie qui sont des rapports de
gendarmerie sur les faits ce qui a été
constaté Jean-Charles denioux vous
pouvez nous lire quelques extraits
rapides de ces rapports le dossier est
d'abord assez volumineux alors voici
quelques extraits importants entre
décembre 74 et le 17 avril 75 5 vaches
ont été abattues à l'abattoir d'Ambert
le vétérinaire constatait chaque fois
que chacune de ces bêtes avait dans la
panse une vingtaine d'aiguilles à coudre
ou d'épingles de sûreté des certificats
médicaux en date des 14 février 75 et 16
avril 76 concluaient que les vaches
avaient dû être abattu à la suite
d'ingestion de corps étrangers alors
voici un exemple le certificat du 17
avril 75 par exemple précise que la
vache numéro
252623 présentait des lésions
importantes et que le bonnet comportait
plus de 300 g de morceaux de ferraille
et comment ce qu'on faisait ingurgie
alors comment est-ce qu'elles arrivent
il s'avère qu'une personne sans doute à
l'aide d'une bouteille remplie d'huile a
fait avaler des aiguilles aux bêtes un
acte de malveillance a donc été consommé
c'est ce que disent les gendarmes
une commission rogatoire délivrée au
commandant de la brigade de gendarmerie
de Saint-Anthème l'adjudant mioche a
conclu qu'aucun commerçant de la région
neuf commerçants ont été consultés n'a
vendu des épingles autour de bises ou
n'a constaté d'achat suspect d'épingles
de sureté et voici la conclusion du
rapport il résulte que l'hypothèse de
l'intervention d'un tiers absolument
étranger aux familles mis en cause n'est
pas à exclure force et cependant de
constater que l'information n'a pu
réussir à ce jeu à réunir à ce jour des
charges suffisantes contre quiconque
dans ces conditions et en attendant la
survenance d'éléments nouveaux le
non-lieu sera requis c'est ce qui a été
fait bien alors le premier que j'avais
interroger c'est Henry Brock Henry Brock
vous êtes auteur d'un livre qui vient de
paraître aux éditions du Seuil le
paranormal je vais pas raconter ce livre
du tout mais disons que dans votre
itinéraire on remarque que vous vous
intéressez très près vous êtes
scientifiques vous êtes physicien
intéressez très près au phénomènes
paranormaux puisque vous étudiez depuis
longtemps vous étiez disons assez
curieux favorable même et maintenant
alors vous êtes entrés dans un
scepticisme c'est
pointilleux et votre livre dénonce un
certain nombre de de ce que vous appelez
des mystifications du paranormal alors
la première question que je vous pose à
propos de l'affaire de Saint-Anthème et
la suivante est-ce qu'il y a une
explication scientifique possible
d'apparition ou de disparition
d'aiguilles même dans une ferme dite
ensorcelée puisque l'acte de
malveillance n'a pas pu être prouvé ce
qu'il l'exclut pas d'ailleurs mais je
crois que le premier point à soulever
dans les reportages qu'on a pu voir
c'est que il n'y a pas d'apparition de
disparition d'épingle à un instant il y
a rien à l'instant après il y a des
épingles personne a vu apparaître ou
disparaître les aiguilles donc la
réalité de la dématérialisation si on
peut dire des épingles est loin d'être
prouvé de toute manière je veux dire
physiquement ça ne tient pas la route
donc la manifestement je crois qu'on a
quelqu'un qui dépose des épingles ou
quoi donc faudrait me donner une enquête
un petit peu plus serré à ce niveau là
on a à aucun moment on apparition je
crois que la question à poser c'est
est-ce que quelqu'un a vu apparaître les
aiguilles c'est-à-dire ce matérialiser
tout doucement les épingles est-ce que
quelqu'un a vu apparaître les aiguilles
une question qu'on peut poser
sous vos yeux voilà vous avez vu je les
ai vu ils ont éteint mais la deuxième
fois je suis passé mais c'est les seules
fois que j'ai vu donc 8 aiguilles qui
ont été
un cierge et l'instant d'après les
aiguilles ont apparus comme ça j'ai tout
ce que je peux dire ah oui d'accord
qu'ils étaient sur mes sur mes charges
et c'est un média j'ai d'ailleurs je me
suis pas découragé pour autant de toute
façon
j'ai enlevé les épingles
les aiguilles sont venues sont apparues
comme ça brusquement sur sur les sièges
ils ont été un message c'est tout ce que
je peux dire moi ce que je peux dire
c'est qu'à partir du moment où une
expérience comme ça se produit qu'un
seul témoin et que c'est pas contrôlé ça
n'a strictement aucune bien sûr ça vous
peut dire bon ben je peux être un
menteur donc ça dans ce cas-là
on peut prendre comme tel ça c'est pour
bien grave moi ça me dérange contre
parole voilà ces paroles contre parole
moi ça me dérange pas de toute façon
vous êtes pas obligé de me croire moi je
sais ce que j'ai vu
on cherche à vérifier d'essai donc c'est
pas bien dans ce cas-là fallait venir
avec nous qu'on fait un exercice alors
là vous verrez peut-être un problème
d'autres exemples il y a des exemples de
de sorcellerie d'abord qu'est-ce que
c'est la sorcellerie peut-être qu'on
peut essayer de donner une définition
comme ça c'est tellement veste enfin
c'est pas tellement il faudrait plutôt
demander un sorcier la définition mais à
mon avis tout ce qui relève de ce qu'on
appelle les phénomènes paranormaux à
savoir je sais pas moi les torsions de
cuillère par le pouvoir de la pensée le
chamanisme tout ça enfin c'est très très
large donc c'est c'est tout ce qui est
au-delà de au-delà de la normale bon moi
là où je voudrais insister c'est que
souvent on dit bon inexpliqué
inexplicable il faut pas franchir le pas
il y a des choses qui sont inexpliquées
il y a pas de choses inexplicables donc
c'est là un petit peu que il faudrait
regarder comment s'occuper de ces
phénomènes bon maintenant si on regarde
un petit peu la littérature l'historique
tout ça il y a toujours des tas des tas
de mystification dans certaines très
célèbres que l'on peut trouver ou que
l'on peut démonter et par exemple bon
par exemple je sais pas dans ce domaine
là bon au début du siècle il y avait
deux petites filles qui prétendaient
voir des lutins et qu'ils avaient
photographié donc on a les photos tout
ça avec des lutins là on a des preuves
en mai on a des photos avec des lutins
ça a duré ça a duré ça a duré jusqu'à il
y a un an et ces deux dames qui
maintenant ont 83 ans 84 ans quelque
chose comme ça en révélé qu'elles
avaient simplement découpé les les
gluten dans un dans un ouvrage et
qu'elles avaient épinglé ça sur des
feuilles elle s'était photographies
réciproquement dans la nature comme ça
et ça a fait les choux gras de tas de
volume pendant X années et décennie
monsieur vinter vous êtes psychanalyste
vous connaissez assez bien
le problème de la
disons des phénomènes de sociologie
rurales urbaine malgré tout vous appelez
à en connaître avoir des cas
particuliers comment est-ce qu'on peut
dépasser ce problème et l'interpréter
entre la mystification ça ressort de
quoi de la mystification ou du rituel je
veux dire qu'est-ce qui se passe là
il me semble qu'effectivement dépasser
le problème ça serait ne pas se situer
dans le débat mystification pas
mystification
il est il est entendu je crois pour pour
la communauté scientifique que jusqu'à
présent la preuve de tel phénomène comme
disait bogue de phénomènes qui seraient
inexplicable n'a pas été faite donc le
problème se pose différemment
vous vous ne croyez pas que les époux je
n'y crois pas
mais ceci dit je n'y crois pas je ne
veux pas dire pour moi que ce phénomène
est sans signification et donc ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de savoir les
conditions dans lesquelles un tel
phénomène est possible qu'est-ce qui
fait que le désenseur seulement
est possible en tout cas dans certains
cas et quelle signification sociale et
psychologique il a alors c'est
évidemment très complexe il est
difficile dans une émission aussi brève
de dire tout là-dessus mais disons que
brièvement
les cas de sorcellerie sont cohérents
avec l'ensemble des croyances des
milieux dans lesquels ces quatre
sorcellerie apparaissent l'ensemble des
croyances qui dépassent d'ailleurs les
croyances explicites des gens c'est à
dire que d'ailleurs vous avez entendu
tout à l'heure les personnes qui ont été
interviewées sur leur croyances elles
n'ont pas grand chose à dire sont des
croyances implicitées ou si elles ont
beaucoup à dire elles le disent pas donc
sur la base de ces croyances il se
produit un moment donné je dirais comme
un décrochage quelque chose
apparaît qui ne fait plus sens dans
l'ordre des liens sociaux auxquels les
gens sont habitués quelque chose
apparaît qui est effectivement
inexpliqué un choc comme par exemple la
mort de ses vaches ou la mort de ses
animaux quelque chose apparaît qui tout
d'un coup vient perturber d'une façon
tout à fait surprenante pour ces gens là
l'ordre de l'ordre des liens qu'elles
ont avec leurs bêtes avec les gens qui
les entourent avec avec la famille avec
avec l'entourage elle pense pas
d'ailleurs forcément tout de suite un
cas de sorcellerie elle pense
effectivement d'abord une malveillance
mais c'est sur le fait que cette
malveillance n'est pas prouvée que tout
d'un coup vient se greffer l'idée qui
d'ailleurs quelquefois le plus souvent
leur vie de l'extérieur le désorceleur
que nous avons entendu tout à l'heure a
dit qu'il avait proposé ses services
c'est-à-dire qu'il a pas été appelé il
est venu de lui-même après avoir entendu
dans la presse ou ailleurs que il y
avait un là quelque chose qui pouvait
relever de sa compétence donc
la famille
est sans et privé de signification
autour de ce qui lui arrive et quelqu'un
vient ça peut être un ami qui fait part
du fait qu'il y a pour cela quelqu'un
qui a une explication alors tout l'enjeu
ça va se passer après entre trois
personnes disons
le dessorcellaire et puis le groupe
social autour et les trois sont partis
prenantes de la terre
le sorcier va livrer un combat avec ce
qu'il appelle le diable
l'exorcisme les raisons de me reprendre
surprise
avec avec le diable incarné d'ailleurs
dans une figure particulière de sorcière
qui n'est pas nommé tout dans le jeu va
être de pouvoir le nommer
il y a un spectacle
vous avez une image à nous montrer le
diable joue un rôle dans sa faire là
pour vous ah oui bien sûr pour vous bien
frock vous êtes exorciste officiel de
l'Église catholique romaine nous a versé
à Rennes vous êtes l'exorciste les
diocèses de Rennes
juste un mot il y a un exercice dans
chaque diocèse pas tout à fait en France
il y a environ 65 exercice juste une
question sur ce problème est-ce que
votre avis le diable a quelque chose à
voir avec ce problème non pour vous non
non
non je ne vois pas comment le diable
interviendrait dans cette affaire nous
allons en reparler tout à l'heure mais
pas dans ces petites affaires disons
très bien
non alors revenons donc alors il y a les
images donc il y a un spectacle il y a
une mise en scène alors dans cette mise
en scène indépendamment du fait de se
prononcer sur le fait qu'il y a
mystification ou pas mystification cette
mise en scène elle est une efficacité
propre
et la question que que me pose ce genre
de de phénomène c'est bien de savoir
qu'est-ce qu'il y a une efficacité
puisque indéniablement il y a des gens
qui vont mieux
la question de savoir si ça dure c'est
une autre problème mais en tout cas
pendant un temps transitoire il y a des
gens qui vont mieux après avoir
rencontré un dessert oui on peut pas
qu'est-ce qui a été efficace d'accord je
suis d'accord avec la question on peut
quand même pas supprimer la question de
savoir qui comment ces aiguilles sont
arrivées dans le ventre des vaches tout
de même et pourquoi la sorcellerie ce
greffe là dessus alors c'est une
question extrêmement vaste la question
de savoir pourquoi elle se greffe là
dessus elle se greffe là-dessus parce
que j'essaie de vous dire tout à l'heure
brièvement il y a un moment donné
rupture des significations il y a un
besoin d'explication il y a une rupture
des significations les significations
qui s'immatent le groupe social ne
suffisent plus d'accord donc on pourrait
dire que la scène d'exorcisme sert aussi
à resimenter le groupe social qui était
en train de se dissoudre du fait donc
les gens sont
les gens sont fous c'est un psychiatre
qui doit aller voir c'est pas un
exercice
expliquez-moi l'apparition des aiguilles
là d'accord
il y a même une disparition de médaille
j'ai mis des médailles de toute façon
ils ont disparu on a fait sortir les
gens pour savoir ça veut dire quoi
disparition ça veut dire un instant la
médaille Estienne instant plus tard de
toute façon on va faire des expériences
tout à l'heure on va aller dans la
cuisine parce qu'on a posé des médailles
dans un terroir non mais je veux dire il
n'y a pas apparition et disparition ou
alors c'est apparition et disparition
comme ça c'est pas une matérialisation
comme on pourrait laisser supposer donc
il faut faire attention aux termes que
l'on emploie c'est-à-dire les phénomènes
qui sont ici revendiqués ne sont pas
prouvés loin de là à l'heure actuelle
tel que ça se passe il n'y a strictement
rien de prouver c'est-à-dire on a des
aiguilles ce qui est prouvé bien sûr
c'est que manifestement il y a eu
actuellement
comme ça toutes les femelles ils sont
passés toutes les femelles il y a un
acte de malveillance ah ben non alors
les lapins c'est pareil ils sont passés
c'est tout pareil alors Henry vous
prenez vous prenez les vous prenez la
chienne c'est pareil c'est tout tous ces
petits sont morts alors ça vient de quoi
alors si c'est du calme qui est passé
pompon allez hop on en parle plus et
après c'est ça
un acte de malveillance mais
et si vous voulez il faut il faut
considérer que la ville c'est pas une
unité et que subissent dans la ville je
dirais différents niveaux de
civilisation ou en tout cas différents
types de liens sociaux on n'est pas tous
dans une ville unie par le savoir
scientifique universitaire par le savoir
imposer dominant il y a des cultures
écrasées dans une ville et des cultures
écrasées qui a certains moments se font
se font entendre se font entendre d'une
façon ou d'une autre contre la science
officielle alors le problème c'est pas
de savoir si les moyens qu'elles ont de
se faire entendre sont pertinents en
regardent à la science officielle le
moyen la question c'est de savoir quelle
est leur pertinence propre à l'intérieur
du groupe social d'accord donc il y a
des sorciers dans les villes il y a des
sourcils dans les vêtements de la
sorcellerie
de sciences parallèle c'est la science
je vous propose maintenant de faire
connaissance avec un autre personnage
un nouveau personnage que je vais
interroger qui s'appelle Patrick Guérin
Patrick Guérin vous avez quel âge 29 ans
vous habitez à quel endroit Paris dans
le 14e Paris dans le 14e vous pouvez
nous dire brièvement votre enfant
niveau de l'éducation enfin bon j'étais
jusqu'au brevet j'ai
fait ma route et c'est quoi votre route
après un CAP quand même deux pâtissiers
et après tout en tant que mécanique un
peu et cascadeur cascadeur dans le
cinéma ou dans le
spectacle j'ai pas été jusque jusque là
surtout spectacle avec des gens connus
puis par moi-même après avec une propre
équipe et puis un propre club où j'avais
monté à l'époque vous gagnez vous vous
gagnez combien à combien estimez-vous
votre revenu annuel vous pouvez le dire
ou pas ou ça vous embête en tant que
quoi
en tant que par le métier que vous
faites aujourd'hui
non je parle tellement envie de dire
vous faites un métier ou c'est difficile
d'en parler directement
non mais c'est pas une question c'est
pas une question d'accord vous êtes
croyant je suis croyant Dieu je crois en
Dieu je crois pas mal de choses et bien
je vous propose de voir un reportage
dans lequel nous allons découvrir qui
vous êtes sorcier
c'est une profession ça
pas vraiment reconnu mais enfin oui
c'est une profession
Patrick Guérin sorcier moderne depuis 5
ans il vend par catalogue des poudres
pour faire le mal et des poupées à
piquer dans leur cercueil avec le mode
d'emploi dans son cabinet il reçoit 20
clients par jour celui qui veut tuer son
voisin celui qui veut retrouver sa femme
même des chefs d'entreprise viennent le
consulter pour augmenter leurs chiffres
d'affaires il se comporte avec ses
clients comme un médecin il casse
l'image du sorcier traditionnel
et je vais voir si vous pourriez faire
quelque chose pour la faire revenir moi
je peux faire une cérémonie pour vous
enfin déjà la première question est-ce
que vous avez des éléments corporels
cheveux ongles j'ai une photo
j'ai déjà regardé avec la photo
ça c'est en fonction de
beaucoup de choses
disons entre deux et trois mille
d'accord on peut le faire l'assistant
s'occupera un petit peu de tout ce qui
est rituel des choses pendant que moi je
vais partir dans l'astral pour rejoindre
son subconscient
et lui faire comprendre que ce qu'elle
fait
et néfaste en fin de compte pour elle et
la ramener imaginer un travail sur David
sur statuette si vous pouvez vous
déplacer
à la cérémonie
et il participait puisque vous allez
donner vous-même un côté émotionnel que
moi je ne peux pas donner
[Musique]
[Rires]
ça c'est difficile de réagir un document
comme ça et je veux dire c'est assez
impressionnant au point de vue quand on
voit le sorcier disant participer parce
qu'on peut remarquer c'est le la
contraction la dilatation du ventre tout
ça qui est ce qui est en terme médical
s'appelle la quatrième au frimeuse c'est
une contraction de l'abdomen alors je ne
sais pas si Monsieur le l'effectue
consciemment ou inconsciemment mais
c'est une contraction de de l'abdomen
blocage de l'abdomen en position basse
et avec des inspirations forcées on
arrive à avoir un ventre qui peut
atteindre le volume de celui d'une femme
enceinte de 8 ou 9 mois et c'était
réputé pour être un miracle jusqu'à à
peu près 1903 c'était un même miracle à
Lourdes et qui a été
démystifié en partie par le docteur
Alfred krans qui avait fait un papy en
1955 justement à propos de ce miracle de
Lourdes du point de vue du miracle c'est
un exercice physique impressionnant
cette ce mouvement du ventre Patrick
Guérin du corps alors déjà je vais pas
l'expliquer vu que c'est la première
fois je le vois maintenant je m'explique
mieux pourquoi je certaines douleurs
après et qui m'oblige d'ailleurs des
fois à stopper toute activité pendant un
petit moment
si vous m'expliquez ça comme ça c'est
très bien maintenant je sais pas du tout
ce qui se passe
c'est une technique à moi que j'ai mis
au point
par d'autres connaissances
c'est tout je peux pas dire c'est la
première fois je vois je suis assez
surpris des images c'est tout
jusqu'à maintenant les clients m'avaient
dit
où les gens qui étaient là m'avaient dit
mais j'avais jamais vu donc je peux pas
se faire photographier ou ne pouvait pas
être photographié j'ai vu une photo de
vous dans un journal de télévision tu as
les 7 jours je croyais que les sorciers
ne pouvaient pas se faire photographier
comment est-ce qu'on devient sorcier
bon on vient à sorcier en rencontrant
d'autres personnes qui travaillent dans
les campagnes qui travaillent en ville
aussi et qui veulent bien vous vous
initier à partir du moment où ils sont
une certaine force en vous certaines
choses certaines choses que moi je
ressens pour d'autres maintenant
alors quand Patrick Guérin dit qu'il va
aller voyager dans l'astral pour
retrouver une personne qui a disparu
pour pour quelqu'un pour aider quelqu'un
à retrouver quelqu'un qui l'aime
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez pour moi ça
représente rien du tout je veux dire il
utilise des termes qui peuvent peut-être
servir à impressionner le client comme
lui-même il a utilisé je veux dire mais
ceci dit ça ne repose sur strictement
rien du tout l'astral je veux dire
jamais personne ne l'a défini je dirais
on peut utiliser des termes on peut
parler de magnétisme on peut parler de
ce qu'on veut ceci dit à mon avis bon là
on a assisté à une séance assez
particulière et assez disant
impressionnante point de vue variation
corporelle tout ça mais qui pour moi ne
relève de rien de particulier sinon du
fait que la sorcellerie si on regarde un
petit peu à mon avis ça devrait être une
profession interdite si les pouvoirs
publics faisaient enfin une profession
entre guillemets
ce qu'on vient de voir en principe tombe
sous le coup de la loi maintenant bon il
se peut que les impôts ne soient pas
tout à fait d'accord parce qu'il prélève
certainement leur dîme donc ça les
intéresse peut-être
du moment que vous faites ça
officiellement vous devez bien avoir une
aventure officielle je suis en bas les
professionnels j'ai absolument le droit
d'exercer et pour quelle pour quelle
profession si on se recule sorcier voilà
ben en principe bon ça je veux dire tout
ce qui est sorcier guérisant c'est
pourtant bien un signe que c'est admis
et que c'est rentré aussi
la personne là que vous avez décidé de
rechercher dont on parle dans le
reportage et revenu ou pas depuis pouvez
nous donner une indication depuis ça non
pas encore mais ça c'est normal puisque
là en partant d'une d'une cérémonie
faite
avec la télévision
on peut pas on perd 80% de son
efficacité donc moi j'ai été amené à
refaire ce genre de pratique et en
modifiant certaines petites choses que
vous voyez par là pour obtenir le
résultat qui doit de se faire là
maintenant et pourquoi vous avez accepté
de faire cette émission de télévision
comme j'accepte de dire la profession
que je fais pourquoi Jean-Charles
denisodermo quelques chiffres sur
les séances de désengroupement il est
pris varient de 100 francs à 12000
francs Gabriel Olivares qui est un
exorciste prends-lui on va voir tout à
l'heure pour lui 700 francs pour 28
jours de travail on fait payer la séance
250 francs les prix des exorcismes vont
de 5000 à 100 000 francs
on a proposé à la famille Tournebise
75000 francs paraît-il pour un exorciste
ils ont refusé bien sûr et enfin une
dernière indication les pentaxes
c'est-à-dire des talismans pour se
protéger ils sont vendus de 2000 à 10000
francs
je crois que le l'argent qui est investi
dans les sciences occultes de manière
générale des passes de manière très
large le budget de la recherche
scientifique alors je crois que ça quand
même ça doit donner à réfléchir et juste
un petit exemple ici bon on verra
peut-être pas simplement ça c'est les
textes de loi celui-là et celui-là qui
montre que ça il y a quand même la loi
qui devrait faire quelque chose mais ce
que je trouve assez assez frappant c'est
que bon le si on regarde le ministère de
la Justice donc en principe ça tombe
sous le coup de la loi mais si par
contre on prend n'importe quel annuaire
téléphonique on prend les PagesJaunes et
on cherche dans les professions donc
après cartographe il y a carte mentielle
ce qui veut dire que officiellement le
ministère des PTT reconnaît comme
profession une profession qui tombe sous
le coup de la loi donc manifestement moi
je pense qu'il faut élargir un petit peu
le débat et au niveau des pouvoirs
publics manifestement il y a l'axisme
qui est à condamné et il faut soulever
le problème il y a quelque chose à faire
là il faut annuler la loi peut-être pas
tout à fait
moi maintenant je vous propose de voir
de passer un peu du côté des gens qui
font appel
à ces pratiques et de regarder un peu
un document de regarder un document qui
est un document assez dur mais qui est
un document donc où on voit un prêtre un
religieux dont je dois dire au départ
qu'il fait 30 à 35 exercices
par mois
alors ceci ce sont des plumes que l'on
trouve dans les oreillers
c'est un symbole justement de
l'envoutement ce sont des plumes quand
vous a apporté oui ce sont des plumes
que les gens m'ont apporté
c'est d'ailleurs à chaque fois que
personne vient pour me demander
justement ce qu'elles ont je leur
demande de suite de regarder
donc dans les pubs
Gabriel magnétiseur radissaisiste prête
exorciste de l'Église catholique
médicale veuillez des foulées à partir
de demain
[Musique]
monsieur olivresse reçoit le mardi à
Biarritz le mercredi à Pau vendredi
samedi toute la journée à Tarbes
ceci c'est une dame qui a reçu cette
carte
et voyez sur l'essence il y a deux
épingles c'est un envoûtement d'amour
qu'est-ce que tu as vu quelque chose que
tu as vu
la mort
ce soir tu verras la lumière
éternel et sa miséricorde infinie amen
comme l'enfant qui monte vers Toi
Seigneur c'est ma prière qui montre toi
Seigneur c'est ma prière qui monte vers
toi comme l'enfant qui monte vers Toi
Seigneur qui monte vers toi comme Lançon
qui monte vers Toi Seigneur c'est ma
prière qui monte vers toi comme l'enfant
Seigneur c'est ma prière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Mère de Dieu toujours vierge Marie toi
vraiment la merde
et de tous les docteurs d'Antoine pas
comme Benoît Colombo
oui c'est la fin de sa roi et de tous
les saints par la prière Seigneur
délivrez-nous du malin qui relisons qui
réalisent
s'il te plaît
de la mort au nom de la sainte Église du
Christ au nom de la foi de tous les
feders serviteurs de Dieu au nom de la
prière de tous les saints suis loin de
cette créature sans lui causer de mal
sans lui laisser la grille de peine sans
la mariée de la trace de ton passage va
t'en ruser maudit prince de la mort mais
ne garde ni sur son corps ni sur son âme
un pouvoir secret
de Dieu
Chantal il n'a plus de place en elle
pour que vous y restiez et plus votre
avis plus grande sera votre
méchanceté
au nom de Jésus-Christ Fils de Dieu
vivant et partez dans le désert car il a
vos nouvelles demeure ne diffusez pas
essuyer sinon vos souffrances vont
grandir quand l'Esprit de vérité vous
construimera de son souffle purificateur
tu nous a donné ta force
éternelle sa miséricorde infinie
c'est bon ne respirer
pour certaines personnes peut-être mais
pour moi c'était pas bon du tout du tout
j'ai pas besoin de raconter ma vie
qu'est-ce qui vous
alors
[Musique]
médicaments
il y a quelque chose d'autre
[Musique]
mon père alors quel est votre réaction
d'abord je parle en mono personnel je
tiens le signaler
ma réaction ça me fait mal ça me fait
mal non pas à cause de ce qu'on vient de
voir là j'ai vu des scènes à peu près de
ce genre pendant que j'étais au milieu
de l'hôpital psychiatrique mais vous
ce qui me fait mal c'est
la peur que ça va causer dans la
population
tous ces pauvres gens qui souffrent qui
ne comprennent pas ce qu'il leur arrive
et on ne fait que les enfoncer dans leur
angoisse et à mon point de vue faire un
exercice dans ces dans ces conditions ce
n'est pas bon
je ne le ferai pas et d'ailleurs il faut
bien le remarquer je n'ai pas un pouvoir
de guérir de cette manière quand mon
évêque m'a demandé d'être exorciste du
diocèse il m'a bien spécifié d'ailleurs
que si j'avais un exercice un jour à
faire il faudrait que je sois d'accord
avec lui qui me donne même qui me
demande de le faire
mais pour faire un exercice il faudrait
avoir la certitude qu'il y a un cas
disons satanique or ici qu'est-ce qui
nous montre que si satanique cette dame
nous dit qu'elle a été guérie d'autre
part par l'exorcisme il n'y a pas de
preuve
un jour on lui a amené une jeune fille
de 22 ans pour laquelle on demandait
également un exercice il y a des bons je
vais chercher de l'eau bénite il est
passé de la pièce à côté il a pris de
l'ordinaire il est venu et aussi tôt
qu'il a pris l'ordinaire et qu'il a
voulu prendre l'ordinaire il y a eu la
crise que vous venez de voir
donc ce n'était pas le béni
mon père pour vous rien ne satanique là
il n'y a rien de satanique
ce qui est satanique voyez-vous c'est la
méchanceté la haine la violence qui est
engendrée dans le monde ce qui est
satindique par exemple c'était les camps
de concentration
et puis alors là on arrive là des choses
qui sont presque burlesques je regrette
de le dire
vous croyez au diable personnellement
personnellement ma passion il faut bien
préciser croire je crois en Dieu
voyez-vous c'est l'objet de ma foi
être fidèle à quelqu'un à la fois c'est
cela
je crois que Dieu Satan existe d'accord
mais je ne vais pas donner voyez-vous ma
foi à satin Henry
il y a une montée de l'irrationalisme ça
vous inquiète oui je crois qu'à l'heure
actuelle par le relais des par le relais
des médias tout ça les les faits qu'il y
avait en rester restreint une petite
zone prenne beaucoup plus d'importance
et je voudrais pour ma part insister sur
le fait qu'il n'y a pas d'envouteur ça
n'existe pas il n'y a que des envoûter
et je crois que ce qu'on peut ce qu'on
peut souhaiter c'est Liam 3 qui l'a dit
avant moi le roi d'Angleterre qui était
obligé de faire l'imposition des mains
il faisait l'imposition des mains et la
phrase rituel qui disait c'était puisse
Dieu vous donner le meilleur santé et
plus de bon sens je pense que c'est ce
qu'on peut souhaiter moi je dirais avant
de conclure que je crois qu'on a le
droit d'être malade mais on n'a pas le
droit d'être crédule je vous souhaite
une très bonne nuit faites de beaux
rêves et surtout ne faites pas de
mauvais rêve et n'ayez pas peur
[Musique]